what's going on guys hello and welcome
to the fourth annual screen EES the
award show that you know and love we're
honoring the best of entertainment in
2015 with a bunch of categories that we
made up right before the cameras started
rolling let's get started shall we let's
kick this off with a doozy the
mainstream movie that sounds like a porn
award the nominees are inside out
daddy's home
Black Mass the big short the longest
ride what we do in the shadows the lady
in the van and the winner yet hard
congratulations get hard you join a
prestigious list that includes bears and
inside Llewyn Davis on the list of
movies some creep accidentally rented
and was disappointed by and by some
creep I absolutely don't mean me
up next the Anna Kendrick award this
award goes to the star who we didn't
realize was totally hot first we
shamefully neglected to hand out this
award last year so we'd like to
retroactively Lee give the 2014 Anna
Kendrick award to Chris Pratt hot star
of guardians of the galaxy and this
year's winner Carrie Fisher Succot aide
shamers congratulations miss Fisher we
deem you an intergalactic cougar even
it's 60 years young you have awakened my
force you made my Jedi return you made
my Empire strike back you gave my Star
Wars a new hope you caused my phantom to
become menacing made my clone attack you
caused my sis to revenge that one didn't
work and now it's time for the teaser
iasts
teaser award and the winner tiny and
manatees even though we hate trailer
trailers ant-man was able to pull off
the ultimate tease the 10-second trailer
that you literally couldn't see any of
Ant Man also won for them what the [ __ ]
is this award for this other trip
ants ants mmm this next award is the
make up your mind award and it goes to
Star Wars fans first the prequels sucked
because there were nothing like the
original movies then the force awakens
sucked because it was too much like the
original movies you [ __ ] about George
Lucas until he sold Star Wars to Disney
and now there's a petition to bring him
back
get it together Star Wars fans anger is
the path to the dark side oh and for
those of you who spoiled the movie for
me on Twitter you I know a lot of people
were looking forward to this one the
best new character award the nominees
ray from the force awakens
bing-bong from inside out XE from the
Kingsman the Secret Service and your
winner the doof warrior from Mad Max
fury road you know what forget furiosa
prequel I want more doof warrior show me
the whole doof band I want the doof
drummer and the doof keyboardist and the
doof lead singer I guaranteed those guys
gonna put on a better show than a
reunited Guns & Roses will at Coachella
Axl doesn't have it anymore
this one scares me because it's about
bad guys it's the breakout TV villain
award the nominees are kilgrave and
Jessica Jones the kingpin in daredevil
Dani Rayburn in the very underrated
bloodline and the winner
everyone in Manitowoc County Wisconsin
congratulations on ruining my holiday
season I was so busy ranting about your
county's broken justice system that I
completely missed Hanukkah Christmas New
Year's I hate the Green Bay Packers and
cheese and anything related to Wisconsin
now good job it is now time for the
worst sequel award the nominees are
yeah sure Avengers age of Ultron is on
there yeah another pitch perfect movie
it's perfect too
and the winner true detective season 2
even in a year that brought us Alvin and
the Chipmunks the road chip
true detective 2 was by far the most
disappointing sequel of 2015 you know I
wish time really was a flat circle so I
could go back and never watch true
detective season 2 next up its the I
didn't think it could get worse award
the winner Adam Sandler somehow Adam
Sandler managed have the worst year of
his cinematic career starring in not one
but two box-office bombs and premiering
an a terrible Netflix original movie the
bad news the ridiculous 6 is now
Netflix's most-watched movie ever you
know where they watched it the most
Manitowoc County Wisconsin that's right
they can't even give crimes against
comedy a fair trial you know what I'm
realizing handling these figures we've
never dusted our set oh we're back next
up it's the thing I didn't think I'd
want a bone award the nominees the robot
in ex machina before she even put her
lady skin on the puppet in anomaly so
this minion in a g-string what could
beat the minion in a g-string you ask
the winner Hermits Natalie Dormer
looking girlfriend on the Muppets and
that's no slam on Natalie Dormer she's
gorgeous that's our way of saying this
pig she's really not so congratulations
Muppets you may not have gotten big
ratings but you opened up a really weird
door to my sexuality jim henson company
if you're watching send us one of those
puppets for our set yeah don't worry
we'll leave it here I won't take it home
with me or anything oh here's an award
we've done before and guess what we're
doing it again the man of steel award
this award is named after Man of Steel
and in the spirit of underwhelming
superhero blockbusters this year is
where
Avengers age of Ultron I guess you were
fine
I saw you didn't hate you I'm having
trouble remembering you you were a
little bit man
Congrats this is the bane award for the
most difficult to understand Tom Hardy
performance the nominees Tom Hardy and
Mad Max fury road oh you know this place
he exists Tom Hardy in the revenant the
six months worked my ass off knock mute
the winner I'm Hardy in legend oh so I
am
Lando is gonna change the power for me
thanks I'm not planning anything I wants
you you covered it you don't even say
how do I run stringing together nonsense
sounds in Mad Max and all the grunting
about pelts in the revenant was bad
enough but in legend Tom Hardy played
two guys that were impossible to
understand Tom you're a great actor I
appreciate your commitment but all those
accents are only easy to understand for
this next award honors the most Awkward
celebrity encounter it is the most
Awkward celebrity encounter award the
nominees Robert Downey jr. for this
British interview that he walked out of
with good reason might I add what are we
doing uh uh well I'm just asking
questions that's all right bye Cara
Delevingne for this cringe-worthy
Morning Show interview also with good
reason we'll let you go then how about
that all right you go take a little nap
maybe get a Red Bull how about that
Jeremy Renner and Chris Evans for
calling Black Widow a [ __ ] also with
you know what not with good reason she's
a [ __ ] and the winner John Travolta and
idina menzel one year after butchering
ms Menzel's name John Travolta doubled
down by awkwardly touching her face
gross mr. troll toe also scores bonus
points for creeping on Scarlett
Johansson on the red carpet keep creep
and John keep creepin this tiny little
guy is for the best splice from jupiter
ascending award we're still putting that
in yep we're still putting that in the
nominees are maledicte ease the owl
splice advisor of kalique abrasax Nash
the elephant splice pilot of the Aegis
ship commanded by doea mika singh
Cannery night a rats place in the employ
of balaam abrasax cane wise the ex
legion half albino runt like inton
splice hunter sent to kidnap Jupiter
Jones by Titus abrasax people say that
Jupiter ascending is a terrible movie
and yep they're right it's very bad
take out your balm it's time for the
Carmex chapped lips award brought you by
Carmex for those chapped lips and the
winner is it's a tie between nicholas
hoult and Mad Max fury road and Leonardo
DiCaprio in the revenant whether set in
the hot desert or the cold wilderness
both of these performances had me
licking my lips and sympathy and
reaching for the chapstick feeling dry
right now it's cracking you oh it hurts
and our final award most ridiculous
piece of Star Wars merchandise whoo the
nominees are Star Wars coffee creamer
they made that yet they made that Star
Wars droid bottled water which would
instantly kill droids Star Wars
batteries Star Wars makeup and the
winner star wars oranges that's right
Star Wars marketed citrus and yet
despite slapping their name on almost
everything in existence they still
couldn't find room to make rey action
figures shame Star Wars shame shame
shame before we go let us take a moment
and remember the people and things that
we lost in entertainment in the year
your movie sucks so bad
you sound real bad
don't screw
it's your fault we all
your movie sucks so bad
you sound real bad
right so down down don't squirt
it's your fault
we all want
well there you have it everybody the
fourth annual screen EES what many
people call the most glamorous night in
Hollywood so what category did you think
of that we should include next year let
us know in the comments section below
best answer we're gonna send you a
screen junkies t-shirt I want to thank
you guys for watching you're awesome
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye when I told you you're gonna
interview Ice Cube and Kevin Hart what
did you say Oh Ice Cube I I love his the
reality show and I love cocoa in the
Bulldog is just great and mom who did
you realize you were talking about I see
right innocent mistake